this is part two of the tutorial on
database link with Wolfram language and
this part covers data types how to query
the database will see some descriptive
commands few data commands and how data
types map and a few examples on creating
procedures and functions now this chart
shows you how the different Mathematica
types map onto sequel types it's very
very easy to understand all the string
types are character of our car long wire
car or real or double float in VL and
same for true it's a bit false is a bit
now is null and then there are three
special types which is sequel binary
which is for binary data and sequel
date/time which is for date/time and x
max timestamp theta and there is the
sequel expression which is for storing
mathematical expressions in the database
and we will see these three special
types and in the next slides now before
that let's go through how to evaluate
queries from within Wolfram language and
to do that we know that there are two
ways in which you can do it
one is the Wolfram language style
queries and sequel style queries
involving language style queries you use
the Wolfram language built-in functions
and provide arguments such as table
names and sequel columns and any
conditionals that you want to provide so
let's try an example here
now open sequel connection publisher
will open a connection to a built-in
database which is called publisher and
sequel tables will list all the tables
that are within that database now we
want to select everything that is in the
sales details table we'll do a sequel
selector on it and if you want to select
certain columns with the condition which
is quantity shipped is
greater than 20 will give a condition
like this with the sequel column
quantity shipped greater than 20 now we
will evaluate the same commands in
sequel style which is by providing just
raw sequel command to a function called
as sequel execute now this sequel
execute is it's like a super function
that can take any sequel command that
you would rather run in your sequel
terminal or standalone database that you
can also run through sequel execute so
same sales details table and you select
everything from it and here you provide
a condition where quantity shipped is
greater than 20 so notice that you are
providing 20 as a parameter here now
this is equivalent to giving the sequel
select command some of the descriptive
commands that are built into database
link our sequel table names sequel
tables and sequel table information so
this these set of commands give you all
the information about that table itself
for example here if you do sequel table
names on the publisher table a publisher
database it will show you all the
different tables that are in that
database and sequel tables give you a
little more descriptive version of the
same let's say if you want to know if
you if there are any views in the
database and you evaluate that with
table type goes to view since there are
none here it returns an empty list and
if you want to know sequel table
information in a lot more detail then
you can evaluate sequel table
information and then show column heading
set to true so if this will also give
you the name of the columns and then its
values similarly you can know more about
the columns and its related information
by using sequel column names by
providing this
table name here you can know what are
the different columns within that table
so you just get the column name you
eliminate this table name and for that
you just need to do all comma two and a
little more information on what each
column name is what their data type is
what the size is to know that just use
column sequel column information so and
similarly sequel columns here so this is
just a list form of the above expression
there's nothing different here it's just
that it's wrapped around this slash
slash table form will give you a nice
table form
easy to view and you have this sequel
show column headings here which you
don't have here so it doesn't show you
the column name separately now data
commands are related to the way you
query data from a database so let me
just make sure that I have a connection
open here and I'm gonna just say okay so
I have our connection open to demo
database again and we will list what are
the tables here so there is one table
called sample table one and let's say we
want to see what are the different
columns in that table okay so we have
three columns and this will give some
information on the connection which we
saw even before also so let's start with
a simple example of creating a table
within the demo database called as test
table so let's do that so I'm going to
and we know that there is no test table
but if it if a table already exists you
can drop it before creating otherwise
it's going to show you an error saying
that the table already exists so we know
that their test table is is not there in
demo database so let's not evaluate this
command so let's just go to
Oh sequel create table and that will
create the test table and now if we see
the list of tables it should show the
new table that we created now we'll
create some data and insert it in the
database so here
this is the list of data so sequel a
test table has two columns one is an
integer and one is warka so we provide a
list of an integer and a worker and we
do sequel insert with the connection
object the table name the column to
which we want to insert the data and the
the data itself you can also insert more
than one column in one sequel insert
statement and for every successful
insert it will return a one so if it
returns a one it means that the
insertion was successful now if you
select from test table you should see
that the columns that you inserted
aren't there now similarly you can just
create a whole bunch of drawers to be
inserted and just quickly do that and
then put it all in one go now if you
want to select from the table just do a
sequel select if you want to update any
values within the table you can use
sequel update and with the with the data
that you want to be updated and for all
the columns that are greater than 5 so 5
of the rows got updated so this will
return you the number of rows that that
changed and if you look at the table
data again you can see that everything
which is above 5 has been changed now if
you want to delete so these are repeated
root let's say we want to delete all the
rows that are greater than 5 just to a
sequel
and again check with sequel select that
there are they are deleted if you want
to drop a table you can always do a
sequel drop table and that will delete
the table from the database now in the
first slide I showed you the datatype
mappings and told that there are three
special types that you should be knowing
about so let's go through those types
the first one is equal binary this is
for storing any binary data so let's say
we have a plot in Mac Marika and if we
want to export it to a chip and convert
it to a binary data so we are doing a
two character code of the exported
string and then just wrapping it with a
head sequel binary now we already have a
connection open to demo database so we
are not going to evaluate this open
cycle connection again let's create a
table called bin data table that will
contain with this data so first create
the table and then insert this binary
data so once it is inserted you can read
it back just like any other database you
can just do a sequel select on it and
it's nothing different here so once you
get back the data you have to convert it
back to a form which you can recognize
like your plot again so you do a from
character code and then do an import
string on it to get back your plot so in
this way you can just store this plot
data in the database using sequel binary
another data type is sequel date/time
now this is also used for storing date
and time information here is an example
so in mathematica date evaluates to that
list and let's say we create a table
called a state time info and we insert
some data into it now this data is you
can see that I am just wrapping this
date with sequel date/time to
let sequal know that we are sending date
time data and then you can also use the
built-in date object function in Wolfram
language to insert the data so this
doesn't need the sequel date time
wrapper this is that is something added
recently in database link package so
this doesn't need the sequel date time
and when you select it it comes back
with this sequel date/time wrapper so
even if you insert as a date object is
going to come back as a sequel date/time
object and then just drop the table
another type is sequel expression so X
equal expression is something which you
can use to store mathematical
expressions as it is in the in the
database so let's say we have this
integrate expression and we create a
table with the column that will store
this expression and just insert that and
when you select it it just comes back to
its sequel expression you can join the
table an important point to note here
would be to see in the documentation how
this sequel expression is interpreted
after it comes back to the language the
function that does it is called identity
so for example here you have the sequel
select expression and then you get back
this expression sine of X square once
you wrap an identity over it it just
grabs this sine of X Square and replaces
it with that expression in this plot
function here so that's how you can just
extract expression out of the sequel
expression
okay so that database link does not have
any special functions or built-in
functions to create procedures and
functions but there is the super
function that is the sequel execute that
can take any raw sequel command and the
same we can use for creating a procedure
so I'm going to show an example here so
we have a connection open to my my
sequel database so I need to log in as
root and I'm gonna actually drop this
table which already exists and recreate
it to just show you that how it gets
created with sequel execute so the
create table command that is in sequel
that the same command you can use it
here with the same syntax and everything
that you would put in a sequel and just
wrap it with a sequel execute command
and give the connection object here
which is my sequel connection and
evaluate that so I get a 0 which means
the table was created successfully and
this table is a weather data table and
has columns city knee city ID city name
start date end date average temperature
wind speed and pressure and we will
create some dummy data to be inserted
into this one and let's say we have that
now and then just to create the
procedure ah it's it's same as how you
create a table here so instead of the
create table command you were just
giving the create procedure command
so I stored this in a separate string
called as proc insert and I will just
wrap a sequel execute around the truck
insert and now the procedure is created
I get a 0 back which means it was
created successfully
now if I want to run the procedure I can
just use call and then the procedure
name and evaluate and you get the data
back here in the notebook similarly you
can create functions and to do that you
just use the regular sequel command
create function with your sequel syntax
and here is an example wherein I have
this function called as get warning and
this works off the weather data table
and and there is a condition here which
which issues a warning if the
temperature is more than 30 there is a
heat warning and if it is not more than
30 there's no warning issued so when we
run this particular function giving it a
city name and so we will know for that
day if there was a warning issued or not
so let's just run this example and just
use equals execute again with your
connection object and the function
string evaluate you get a 0 the function
was created successfully and to just
call the function you can just use a
select or you know just get the get
warning function put an argument from
weather data and evaluate that and then
we know that there is no warning issued
so whatever is the function and whatever
is the data that you get back you get
back in the Wolfram language and within
your notebook and then it's just a list
of any it's just a list of data like any
other data that you can use further in
your computation or for any other
importing or exporting or modeling
anything so that's the tutorial on
getting and running the database
commands and there's a bunch of
resources available let me show you this
one by one this is the one on data types
so we
a datatype mapping thing which is the
same here and each of these data types
has a separate documentation page which
you can go to and just go through the
various examples that are there and the
querying the database has its own set of
functions so selecting updating
inserting deleting and all the different
functions that you can use from within
the language right here now there is a
separate section on the sequel binary
sequel date/time and set its equal
expression they have their separate
detailed documentation which you are
seeing here right now and last one is
equal execute and sequel execute have
supports a parameter form also and
that's also demonstrated in this
documentation let me just quickly show
you the user guide here
so this is the database link user guide
and there's a lot more in it than the
topics that we covered here so in the
descriptive commands and data commands
specifically you can see how to create
schemas and catalogs and a little more
detailed on every topic and saving
queries and how to use the connection
tool how to use the new connection
wizard so this is pretty much half the
way into the database user database link
user guide and the next section is part
three of this tutorial which deals with
a slightly more advanced topics of batch
insertion and how to use data base link
with cloud and how to deal with database
link when you have large sets of data